In our definitions so far,
we've limited our flow networks
in several ways to make our
treatment of them a little simpler.
Before going any further,
I want to show some tricks of the trade
that will allow all of the theorems and
algorithms that we'll study to be
applied to more general networks.
One such limitation is the need for
all the capacities on
the edges to be integers.
We can extend all our arguments
to rational capacities,
just by multiplying
the capacities by the least common
multiple of the denominators
to create integer capacities.
So in this case, I would simply
multiply all the capacities by six.
This just amounts to a change of
units in our measurement of the flow.
Another limitation we've imposed is that
no antiparallel edges are allowed in
the network.
This forces us to choose a direction for
the flow between every pair of vertices.
In general, however,
it might not be clear in which direction
the flow should go before
solving the max flow problem.
It's possible to cope with this
situation with some slightly less
elegant analysis or just to convince
yourself that the theorems still hold,
add an artificial vortex
between the two nodes and
create two edges to simulate
a reverse flow in this direction.
Another limitation of our model is
that we've limited ourselves to having
a single source and a single sink.
At first, it would seem like we
couldn't handle a network like this one
where we have two sources and
three sinks.
Actually, however, this situation
is quite easy to deal with.
We can just add an artificial
source node and
connect that to the others
with an infinite capacity.
And similarly, add an artificial sink.
So don't let that limitation
trouble you either.